hey mando we know you're a man of few
words but can you say whoops after the
fourth installment of the Mandalorian
hit Disney Plus fans took to the
Internet and droves to point out that
the episode had fallen prey to one of
the oldest most common boneheaded errors
in filmmaking history the old boom mic
in the shot gasps the mistake occurred
roughly 16 minutes into the episode as
the mandalorian was having a chat with
O'Meara the farmer who had given him
refuge during a stop on the planets
organ their conversation took place in a
rather dimly lit area and unless you had
your screens brightness turned up pretty
high it was fairly easy to miss but once
you know it's there it's impossible not
to see it the mic comes creeping in from
the top of the frame then bobs around a
little bit it's even visible for
multiple angles
obviously on Twitter mando fans were
split pretty evenly between well this is
just an excusable and geez cut the crew
some slack while it might seem like a
series with the Mandalorians high
profile should be able to avoid making
one of the most well worn production
errors in the book the fact is that the
series is actually produced by human
beings and darned if human beings don't
drop the ball every now and again yes
there were a great many dangers involved
but perhaps the most dangerous was the
poisonous fish all in all it's really
not worth pulling the ears off your gun
dark the gaff basically amounted to an
out-of-place dark blob intruding on the
frame in an area where viewers eyes
aren't trained to look it's not as if an
item which clearly had no place in the
show's fictional world was left
prominently in the frame as astutely
noted by one Twitter user who wrote
quote it's still better than the Game of
Thrones coffee cup and hey if it's
really shattering your immersion like so
many poorly built death stars just
pretend it's a droid or something we
present to you BM MC the galaxy's first
personal audio amplification droid
action figures coming Christmas 2020 all
joking aside you may be curious as to
whether any other such ridiculous
mistakes have made it into the Star Wars
franchise one of the most beloved in the
world the films of which have been
dissected and analyzed frame by frame by
legions of dedicated fans for decades
the answer oh yes
oh god just so many in fact you may not
have realized that one of the most
famous errors in the entire series
actually was an error because home video
releases starting with the DVD release
have made it appear intentional in Star
Wars Episode four a new hope when a trio
of stormtroopers burst into the Death
Star control room in pursuit of our hero
the one on the right just clocks his
head on the doorframe since the sound
effects for the sequence were added in
post
there was no accompanying clunk when
this happened after fans caught the
mistake just such a sound effect was
added for the home video version but
don't let them fool you the actor
portraying the clumsiest stormtrooper in
the galaxy absolutely did not mean to
give himself a concussion while making
his big entrance there are plenty more
examples to be found in a new hope alone
many of them having to do with c-3po it
turns out that the shiny reflective
quality of the droids dome wasn't
exactly accounted for in a number of
shots in which camera operators and our
cameras are visible in it there are also
several instances of crew members
briefly wandering into the frame and yes
one shot corrected for home video
releases in which the boom mic is
visible as Luke Skywalker arrives at the
moss eisely cantina and his land speeder
movie mistakes comm list a whopping 279
errors in the film par for the course
for the movies of both the original and
prequel trilogy which all contain a
similar number of mistakes and no we
still just mean mr. Binks of course most
of these fall within the realm of simple
continuity errors objects jumping from
one hand to another or things on a table
rearranging themselves between cuts for
examples which are common to just about
all movies but although the sequel
flicks have cleaned up their acts just a
bit it's safe to say that the Star Wars
franchise has a long history of bloopers
and blunders which somehow survived the
editing process to make it all the way
to the screen so yes we're inclined to
come down on the side of giving the
hard-working guys and gals who bring us
the mandalorian the best new series on
television by virtually any measure a
break unless and until that is a future
episode ends up with a shot of a
discarded Big Mac carton chilling on the
control panel of mando ship check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and it's a bell
so you don't miss a single one
you